à ce qu'elle tienne toutes leurs
responsabilités merci la parole est à
monsieur eric straumann merci merci le
saut président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
le numéro un mondial de l'électroménager
a annoncé ce mardi la fermeture de son
usine d'amiens qui compte 290 salariés
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
exprimé hier dans cet hémicycle votre
détermination à ne laisser aucun salarié
au bord du chemin
vous avez reçu le président de huit
pôles qui est venu spécialement des
etats-unis pour lui rappeler que la loi
florange oblige des entreprises qui
ferment à mettre la totalité des moyens
dont elle dispose sur la table pour
permettre la reprise la poursuite de
l'activité industrielle et le maintien
de la totalité des emplois
hier sous la pression de françois long
de françois hollande notre président de
la république
le conseil d'administration d'edf a voté
un accord
actant la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim et donc la suppression de
2000 emplois
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
est simple et j'y associe mon collègue
michel sordi
allez-vous convoqué le président de la
république
comme vous l'avez fait avec le président
veut ouvrir poule pour lui demander
quelles sont les propositions sérieuses
et crédibles de réindustrialisation du
site de fessenheim
merci verrerie la parole est à madame
ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement si monsieur le président
monsieur le député mesdames et messieurs
les députés ce sujet je pense ne devrait
pas nous opposer
je crois que nous avons à trouver
ensemble des solutions intelligentes
pour l'avenir et comme vous le savez
monsieur le député vous plaît beaucoup
on est préparé plus ancienne de france
elle est construite sur une zone
sismique
elle bénéficie d'une dérogation ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui quand une centrale
est construite elle n'a plus le droit
d'utiliser le système de refroidissement
par pompage direct dans le rhin et que
cette autorisation en tout état de cause
de fonctionnement s'arrête au 31
décembre 2022 mais sans doute s'il y a
des contentieux avant cette date
c'est pourquoi nous avons la
responsabilité d'accompagner la mutation
industrielle de ce site
et comme vous le savez puisque ce
processus maintenant est en cours je
vais pouvoir débloquer les
investissements dans une dynamique
franco allemand puisque les allemands
avaient suspendu leurs investissements
industriels sur cette zone autour du
projet premièrement dur l'installation
d'une usine de fabrication de batteries
de troisième génération pour les
véhicules électriques
deuxièmement nous allons pouvoir
positionner ce territoire comme
territoires de projet pour
l'implantation de l'usiné
tesla qui doit venir en europe et
troisièmement je souhaite que ce site
devienne un site exemplaire en termes de
démantèlement des centrales nucléaires
puisque il ya 400 centrales nucléaires à
démanteler à travers le monde et par
conséquent il ya là une filière de
développement industriel majeur
j'ajoute que contrairement ce que vous
voulez dire il n'y a pas de 1000
suppressions d'emplois la totalité des
emplois sont maintenus sur ce territoire
et plus le travailleront vite à la
mutation industrielle vers les emplois
du futur plu nous donnerons de l'espoir
à ce territoire qui le méritent
merci madame la minus